[Music]
hello everyone i am bill and welcome to
this very special nintendo treehouse
presentation of no more heroes three
i'm here with tyler and we're going to
take you through the paces of the game
say hello tyler
everyone um if you know the series you
know that this is developed by
grasshopper manufacturer
and by suda goichi aka suda51
also known as perhaps the most punk rock
game developer in the industry i love
suda and what he brings to these games
he is a hardcore indie developer
and he brings a real punk rock diy
spirit the game is full
of tons of action and a lot of
irreverent humor
but tyler why don't you tell us a little
bit about uh this particular game
and our hero travis touchdown so no more
heroes three
uh this takes place nine years after no
more heroes two desperate struggle
um that's within the games it's been
quite a few years since uh numerous two
came out on the wii
and two years after travis strikes again
no more heroes which was a spin-off but
there are a few elements that
you will see in this game as well from
there so
we are now going to be taking control of
travis touchdown who numerous times
uh climbed to the top of the uh
the assassin rankings to be the number
one ranked assassin he is
a passing assassin but also uh he's
an otaku who loves his anime waifus and
pro wrestling and all sorts of movies
music and a lot of references do come
out and you even hear them in the game
and it really shows his passion for the
things that he loves while he goes
around and kills
his various enemies in this case aliens
who have invaded planet earth and now he
needs to get to the top of the galactic
superhero rankings
great well we're just a couple months
from launch the game launches on august
27th so today we are going to show off
the
sort of enhanced battle system of no
more heroes 3 and we'll show a little
bit of customization and then we'll
finish with a very special final battle
so should we jump into gameplay tyler
yes let's jump in right away
so let's start a battle and i'm playing
with
two joy-con controllers because the
added motion
does seem you know make a lot more fun i
think
but you can play without them so basic
moves
some heavy moves
and as you can see uh travis's main
weapon is his beam katana
uh you can use that to block incoming
enemy attacks like that
um you've also got as you noted your
your standard moves your
your strong moves you've got some kicks
you can use as well to kind of disorient
your opponents
and then in the bottom right you've got
a little meter there
and as you fill that meter it creates
this roulette um and the roulette will
spin and if you manage to line up
uh three icons like you just did you get
a little bonus and i wasn't paying
attention
and my energy gauge is down so oh yes
with the charge of beam katana just like
we've always had to
that's right the uh the beam katana runs
out of energy
as you use up uh your attacks you don't
have to use motion controls but i do
every time
and then with the successive attacks you
get that kind of finishing move there
there you go with another roulette and
let's see if we can
do a perfect dodge these guys are a
little tricky
all right let's just take them out some
heavy moves maybe put him into a stun
mode with some stars above his head nope
we're just going to finish him off
there you go
then i should probably use my death
glove it only has one
ability in right now and of course the
death glove is
uh basically a new power up sort of that
uh that travis has in this game correct
right it's uh first made its appearance
and travis strikes again no more heroes
but that was more of a spin-off it's
kind of fun to see
some of those elements make it over to
this one as well
all right let's see can we stun these i
think we got some stun off nope i'm just
gonna finish them
all right nope nothing on the roulette
this time now of course the other thing
you can see here is uh
grasshopper manufacturer takes uh quite
a bit of inspiration from retro gaming
you can see that in
the pixelated meter down below of the
cat that sort of transforms into the
tiger as you fill it up
you can see the pixelated health gauges
of the uh the aliens and uh
travis's own pixelated heart gauge and
energy gauge with the battery there but
um
lots of uh lots of fun sort of retro
inspired hints all throughout the game
and the series
come on
all right let's finish this there you go
for this game each alien
they have their own blood colors so
every alien bleeds a different color
this one was a little closer to red
is uh is there anything else you can
tell us about these aliens
all these aliens also have they have
their different unique designs
attack patterns and you'll have to use
various strategies to make sure you can
take them out as a lot of them might try
to attack you at the same time
so now i i notice here that you got a
c rank are you planning on maybe coming
back into this stage later and see if
you can improve that rank oh for sure
and
with some of these extra pickups right
here at the end
that will be used for some of our
customization options later
oh yeah tape deck
vinyl doll it's been a while since i've
made my own mixed tape since i have to
take
with the tape deck all right
so if you don't mind we're gonna load
into a different part of the game
okay
here's a map and
[Music]
here we are so i think we're gonna head
back to
the motel the no more heroes motel is
that correct
that's correct and that is travis
touchdown's home base
so we'll get to see where he spends his
time in between uh all of his
uh assassinations
it's probably uh increasing his anime
waifu collection
and yes you do save on toilets in this
game just like every other before
so we're in travis's pad i don't have
any capsule toys so there's nothing in
my toy collection at the moment we're
still a little early in the game
right here uh here's the bed and you can
see his posters for all of his anime
waifus
yep it's got a nice little fire pole
let's
drop down to the next level who needs
stairs right that's right
let's uh let's check out the wardrobe
so you're gonna be able to collect a
variety of t-shirts
let's take off travis's jacket just for
a little while
i've got various colors any colors uh
you'd like to see bill
um how about yellow let's see do we got
a yellow oh we got a yellow there we go
all right and we'll put that jacket back
on i mean we could also you know go into
pajamas but let's uh
let's let's keep it let's keep it this
way with your yellow shirt
all right some other fun things that you
might come across
in travis's pad is
oh is that gene his cat
you can play with gene oh look that's so
sweet
of course do you get anything for
playing with gene or is this really just
all about playing with the cat
you get nothing you just i mean you get
to play with the cat
i mean what else do you want what else
more could you ask
that's right so you're trying to trying
to throw the ball into
the circle yes and then gene will dive
and bat it away
yes and it gets progressively more and
more difficult over time
uh and then the i think the ring gets
smaller and
how the ball gets placed it starts to
get a little more
aggressive if you don't do it right
well gene isn't very happy with you
[Laughter]
yes gene yes yes there's some of that
classic
uh no more heroes humor
and jeans getting bored right okay i'll
try to get it in
the ring this time for real all right
very happy gene
okay all right maybe that's enough gene
for now
that hurts but i scored five but
yeah five high score five points not bad
you'd always come back
and play with gene why not i always get
to play with the kitty
so obviously lots of little things to do
here in in travis's motel room but as
you can see the pole
actually goes down another level
and here are where we can find some of
our customization options so
let's talk to naomi who is very nice
we're gonna do some upgrades here the
power up machine
oh yeah so we have our
world uh world and supernova which is
kind of like our energy currency
to boost some of these so let's increase
my health a little
of course you always want more attack
and that's currency that you earn
through battles and completing missions
and you bring them back bring it back
here and start
upgrading travis and his abilities
that's correct you can even see some of
these other special attacks
which are super cool
oh and i do want them but i definitely
don't have the currency at the moment
but yeah
ooh mustang dodge let's uh gotta start
somewhere though right
you can see how much so what did you do
what did you just add there
uh this one was uh dash attack
great all right and we got a little left
so let's add to our power there
that makes it so the beam katana will
not run out of power as quickly
that's correct oh there we go a few more
other things that we notice
is uh there is a time machine so you
could come back and
challenge previous bosses you've
defeated
and here we go to the super computer so
let's create
some chips so i think you noticed that
uh we collected some enemies like a
tape deck in our last battle
this is there you go some radio and tape
deck parts so let's make a great ship
damage taken goes up a little bit
i love these retro references makes me
want to make more
equip it so you equip that to the death
glove and then that's uh
increasing your attack power slightly
increasing the damage you take
yep that's a good gamble i think yeah
these sounds some other fun
options you can order sushi in the game
you will come across
some stands to buy sushi yeah
but you can also order it to go so
i'm going to go with a personal favorite
maguro this does
replenish health and eating during
battle i know bill like
can we get your order uh i will take
some ikura today i think
all right temporarily increases attack
we got a bit more to go through anything
else um
maybe a little tamago not bad
increases tension all right
that gets delivered to you
when you make your call then you can use
those uh in battle to help replenish
health and things like that that's
correct and then here's a tutorial room
if you want to go and revisit some
tutorials i'm just really impressed at
this motel i don't i don't know that
i've ever seen a motel that's uh
got three floors and in your room and
this amazing lab
at the bottom it's pretty standard for
me that if i stay at a
motel it needs to have this uh you know
really cool sakura tree somewhere
in the vicinity that's right
all right are we ready to load into a
boss battle
yeah i think we'll get to see a little
bit of
travis touchdown's signature irreverence
and style in a ufo
yeah i mean you can just get a sense of
you know overall this game is and the
series as a whole has kind of a
as i mentioned a very kind of diy punk
ethic to it sort of a
grindhouse style if you will um in terms
of their approach just to
totally differ the content and the
visuals so if they're technology
also jean has always sounded like this
so don't worry about it
it's a pretty deep voice for james
just remember that earth also counts as
a planet in space
noted bloodthirsty people are generally
the same everywhere
travis makes a good point let's go
this is gold joe he is number nine
in the galactic superhero rankings okay
so
uh travis needs to defeat him to move
his way up in the rankings that's right
he has to defeat nine to become nine
well joe looks pretty spectacular
it's a fabulous light show
travis is in a place hope you like it my
hyper modern artwork
i project images relevant to one another
onto physical matter
making it seem as though there's a
beautiful space existing right there
it's cutting edge magic so projection
mapping right
i'm already sick of seeing that [ __ ]
with this sort of thing from like the
second time you see it yeah travis knows
it all he understands what's going on
you can't not see it as fake oh snap
snap crackle you guys on earth are
really something
to think that you'd be ahead of us in
this sort of artwork
also that's way too much time wasted on
something like simple projection mapping
don't waste budget money on [ __ ] like
this
oh snap snap crackle
and pippity poppity i have to give gold
joe
some extra points on those reactions
well i can tell you travis is certainly
not earning uh any favor with gold joe
at the moment
that's for sure
so you're going to use blue and red
magnetic north south to bust out some
just slightly puzzlish attacks right
travis knows everything already
that's what i thought bingo okay i'm
just gonna put this out there
for red throw up an n mark above your
head i'll have this throw up an
s for blue that'll make it simpler
gamers like that kind of thing
i don't know if i can do exactly as
i like how gold joe's ready to comply
i'll try my best
nice that's right show me a good time
first travis touchdown breaking the
fourth wall as always
all right so a lot of things are going
on right now
yeah uh gold joe has changed his
polarity so i want to match that
and i can use it to push him into the
electric fence that's right so
basics of of the way magnetism works if
you have
different polarities the two of you will
attract gold joe would
pull travis touchdown towards him to
change your polarity you run over
either the red or the blue square to
change to that color
and then if you've got your polarities
matching uh travis touchdown can use
that to push gold joe
into these electrified boundaries of the
ring
if you notice up top gold joe has his
health bar in
three segments uh that will determine oh
i did a perfect dodge nice let's see if
i can get something
yes oh there you go all right throw
crazy mode activated
so let's see if we can get a toss in and
yes there you go nice little
suplex so saying about the uh the phases
i need to watch out because there's not
going to be a special animation to tell
you the phase has changed
but so now he's summoning projectiles
enough to be on uh on my watch once
these phases change
because it'll make things a lot more
difficult
if i'm not careful all right push them
away but i do need to fall in battle
once to show
everyone watching what happens if you do
fall during a boss battle
so let's see
nice he filled the gauge again but got
nothing on the roulette
all right i will oh i meant to have him
push me in there
but let's see i'll just your uh
katana is running low on energy
i need to show everyone what happens if
you are
unsuccessful nope
okay
so it's gonna say you did
[Laughter]
if you choose to retry which i'm gonna
do you have this roulette
did i get a bonus and no bone nothing in
particular to report
but you might get a bonus which i was
really hoping for
okay tell me stop
stop all right
all right one and a half times attack
power thank you sylvia and thank you
bill
there you go now we're gonna get this
done
all right let's do this
nice dodge
all right perfect dodge very nice
oh you got some uh some of your
additional currency there but no bonuses
for the battle
oh gotta watch out oh come on
let's push them away oh help this time
you're gonna have to get some uh some
energy going there
and you probably want to switch polarity
push them into the fence
there you go all right let's get some
heavies in
let's get a bonus we get a bonus okay
we've got more currency you got more
currency
but we're still operating with that one
and a half times attack power
all right push him away all right we got
him into the third phase
come on you've got him to phase three
hopefully you've got him on the ropes
now
oh get there's my way push him away
all right
oh
oh and you got more currency
at least this battle is going to pay off
for you
finish this there you go
third time's a charm that was three
times right
think so
at the very end you always have to make
sure you get the job done
so it's my favorite that's prompt
cool
now of course this is just one of the
boss battles in no more heroes three
one of the things that i'm really
excited about for the game is just the
sheer variety of bosses i think there
will even
be some that may leave people surprised
at
what they're going to end up doing in
some of those battles wow
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff
into this game and i'm hoping everyone
will continue to be surprised as they go
through it everything
that's why it makes such good money
all right well i think that wraps up our
demo for today
um unless there's anything else you
wanted to add tyler
i think we have a special message from
suda51 himself
that's right let's take a look
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
um
i think we saw in there from from
suda-san that there's going to be some
special bonuses tyler you want to talk
about those a bit right so for those of
you that
have saved data from no more heroes no
more heroes to desperate struggle
these are the uh the remasters on a
nintendo switch
and save data from travis strikes again
no more heroes you'll get a shirt
specifically travis's main shirt from
those games
that you can then wear in this game so
very exciting stuff
great thank you all for watching you can
catch all of our nintendo treehouse live
segments
um uploaded onto youtube very soon if
they're not there already
so hope you'll check them all out and
thank you for watching no more heroes
three and remember it launches on august
27th
that's right so stay tuned and hopefully
you'll check the game out when it's
available pre-orders start on eshop
hopefully very soon great thanks
everybody
[Music]